on approche de la vérité sur le mystère
de l'inviter fine un peu divine super
copine très maligne c'est clémentine
célarié à l'interview promo elle a tout
ce qu'il faut qu'au ministère tous les
lundis lundi dernier je vous mets télé
je trouvais sur les cinq en train de
faire la clé si vous le samedi soir
était sur l'a2 on va le faire lunettes
noires at-il gagneuse
mais son salut au cs faire là-bas au
théâtre non parce que tu sais c'est
notre entreprise avec christophe on
cherche on a touché tous les deux on a
fait une petite société
on n'est pas beaucoup d'argent parce que
mon croix continue pour son loca pass a
commencé au mois deux mois de juillet
lorsque ça et ça c'est ça continue ce
consultant tellement ça marche
oui ça s'appelle marcel à ces outils le
chalet en passant très imposant suis pas
venu on retire les rangs métro avoir
pour se garer un bordel pas possible là
bas car cette vidéo donc c'est au coin
de la place clichy et des élancements
8h30 quoi tu as dit c'est le le rôle que
le cinéma ne m'a jamais offert dire que
tu fais pendant une heure et demie ce
que tu faisais pendant dix minutes et
demie au cinéma c'est ça oui enfin à 10
minutes avant le tir ont montré ce qu'il
savait et a laissé faire
mais non mais celle que ce qui
heureusement qu'ils n'ont pas faire ça
parce qu'il pouvait pas imaginer tu veux
parce que moi je crie quand une femme ça
il faut pas crier ne pas parler trop
fort tu vois que je profite d'un
personnage qu'on avance et christos
comme ça on se dit tiens dedans on va
mettre tous mes tours on prend c'est une
maîtresse qu'elle apprenne fiancée leur
plein de bon sens un accident classé
suite wallon
si dans cette maison par cet appel elles
apprennent tout est évidemment mais les
miels et bien un truc quand même pas
rien gâcher sa distance et que l et es
les différences voyez ça quand même
on voulait vous le faire quelques
indications parce que la différence et
les gens différents qui souffrent
quelques fois et alors qu'ils devraient
pas soutenir
elle est différente elle est heureuse
qu'elle ait les gens allaient être
bonnes
oui mais ça et les seuils voilà ça fait
classe ya quoi et oui je me souviens
amoureux et je me souviens parce que tu
veux maintenant j'en demande quelquefois
des trucs aux jambes et les bras croisés
pas croire là j'ai participé je pense
pas fait-on pas dit et je crois ça met
gentiment tu vois on fait des bêtises
alors je vous demande d'aider gorille
quand on fait du cinéma on fait comme si
les maps et des gorilles dans la jungle
des risques d'attraper banane glissée
dans le bourg seul oui il n'attrape pas
les banales ya pas de bananes cet art
qui navigue en fait et ils font quand
même des gorilles qui prend la mer quand
on sait que c'est la mère et où il
participe à l'heure des deux veuves et
ils le font avec eux enfin comme ça
génial et le samedi sauf que ce qu'ils
font restons dignes
voici